My dear people and friends of otanche Boyacá,
tell them that they also
we are part of this warrior guild,
of this guaquero and mining guild that struggles day by day.
to seek to improve the quality of life
and the welfare of all their relatives,
tell them that the municipal council
we will seek to ensure
the rights of all those of us who struggle day by day
to seek a better life for all
and that is why I want to invite you to support
to this great friend of yours,
to this warrior who is also part of this team
of miners,
I would like to invite you to join me this October 29th.
voting for the Green Alliance party
number 8 to the council of the municipality of Ostancho,
Boyacá.